hi I'm Mario Batali we're making pizza
margarita a classic pie with just tomato
mozzarella and basil just like a
pizzeria in Naples except we're making
it in a home kitchen so there's only one
dangerous moment in creating the use of
yeast and that's that your temperature
of your water has to be about blood
temperature we want it around 98 or a
hundred if you got that in your gold you
can see the yeast is now puffing up it's
making its move it's actually starting
to live because it's feeding on the
sugar if you had put salt in there
already it would have slowed down the
growth because the salt actually kills
it the key to all pizza and pasta is
understanding that the bread or the
noodle is everything like real pizzas
made with exactly these ingredients
don't thing they have is a 500 degree
oven so it pops up more this won't puff
up so much but it'll puff up anybody can
make this that's why it's such a good
thing I cook for my family all the time
but I cook for like our holidays like
I'm the kind of guy that in August I'm
mapping out my New Year's my Christmas
and my Thanksgiving menus getting them
all in order deciding to wine I'm a
Virgo that's where we live how much we
can do about that so when I'm looking at
the pizza I need the frame and the crust
to be really fundamental the sauce is
important but it can't be a cook sauce
it can't be really spiced up it just
needs to be San Marzano tomatoes or Pomi
tomatoes just pure tomatoes that's it
with a little salt cheese anything you
want to go at for me a little mozzarella
and not very much is really good because
Americans tend to confuse abbondanza for
being better than balanced or even
minimal about a bone dance that means
abundance which everyone thinks to mean
that the more stuff you put on it the
more Italian it is but it isn't
Italian is all about balance so I'm
always looking for less stuff on it
higher quality and a char around the
base and on the bottom because the char
that almost not quite burnt but
blackened deliciousness really allows me
to taste the full spectrum of flavor
from the sweetness of the tomato to the
dairy of the cheese the high point of
the basil and then the fundamental
warmth of the wheat in the crust that is
what pizza should be
Oh
you